the first thing I want to say on this
what the [ __ ]
Thursday is it once the [ __ ] Thursday
well it's what the what the [ __ ]
Thursday because this is variable it's
very important for everybody to know
that Brendan's drive her car the car he
drives every day I'm a my everyday
number one everyday car the GTC was this
is the gt2 RS is very important said er
yeah it was an M R now now in keeping
with the times
Brendan's Porsche the car he drives
every day has fire fire coming out of
the exhaust has the ability to shoot
funny because he had its soup to 900
horsepower cuz that's what you need on
the 4 or 5 now listen there's no traffic
right now there's no traffic but but
still can be traffic right but your boy
might be in Texas who was no traffic yes
but but so so we can't know that car
that car is aerodynamic that car
actually can fly I don't know if let you
guys know that but he has the ability to
get it off the ground and fly through
the air and he just needs a couple of
small wings on the Schaub airlines it's
sha sha Breeland it's called sha Barons
only fit now I have a roll cage so we
have no back seats as the world burned
there's a roll cage in the back now as
we have racial turmoil as we have kovat
19 Brendan decides I got the answer I'm
gonna soup my car up to 900 horsepower
and I'm gonna drive around with fire he
sent me a video of fire coming out of
the chrysalis and I questioned supplier
now to close like like it was a it's
like half a dragon he's got a dragon car
it's so funny the different dynamics of
our friends cuz I said to you and Chris
and you know you guys make fun of me I
think the rogen he does goddamn I love
that of course he does rogon the
extremist motorist I read you know well
are extremists but you took theirs in
our group of friends there's only three
car enthusiasts it's and this is he's
kind of he lays low about it but wait
who may wait I might know you so it's
you it's Rogan bro Rogan lot says number
one is way more cars than me okay it's
you a now now the fast car out of any of
them so watch your P's and Ken it might
be I know Russell Peters loves cars uh
he loves cars but he's not a you know
he's not a gear okay we know
we know Corolla and we know oh whoa well
crow I'm not cruel stalking more of the
crew okay so you turn I love her for all
things that like our boy my mother crew
um I don't know you say like Tommy
Stewart crew yeah it's a girl
Oh is he big cart guy I didn't know that
big he's a he's you don't talk about it
you know he's not like me to tell people
what he does and big car guy he's a big
car guy big car guy really he's super in
his you know crazy doll yeah he's like
me let's take some yesterday I'm like
why are we like this he's like I don't
know we're constantly pushing the
boundaries I'm like there's nothing that
I can't do anything else like that's the
as facet that it reset the record I had
more horsepower it's so weird but wait
do you hear it no I'm sure he brought it
last night I was like oh dude we have to
leave it outside he goes why I'm like
it's gonna wake my kids up my neighbors
gonna be pissed it's so loud that's your
car yeah it's a race car
well chin took a video ok well listen
you know congratulations I mean oh there
we are let's see this and this is I
didn't open up the valve the camera
can't capture the actual audio it's so
loud don't they can ask oh it sounds
pretty bad
listen that air whistle no turbo I send
you the video of his shooting fire on
the highway chin no how do you get it
[Music]
the fans just so they know now daddy
went to daddy had some interesting
interesting time yes i went to san
diego-la jolla one of your favorite
birth my favorite place in the world
yeah well I had a move there I know I
know I understand I understand I I
personally think you might get bored
there at the end of the day Texas or La
Jolla La Jolla no papa
yo chill I know and I went to my boy
Tony's house in Encinitas it's beautiful
you can get some houses and some views
so cheap it's not cheap though is it no
but goddamn we're here and the weather
is goddamn nice and I will see the best
it's the best and then they got the rock
something coffee up there oh yeah now I
had to go to health nucleolus craig
venter the venture capitalist futurist
slash longevity guru I went there to get
a very expensive checkup
you didn't yeah hey did you fart no I
didn't but it smells like hey it's your
egg egg okay but then you're talking
like what smells like far didn't I say I
walk through the bathroom I go it smells
like poop I'm like oh well Brian farted
ideas Mel's like an old man smells like
sulfur it was it's your egg I sound it
out on cattails like it smells like ass
and she's like what why is this not
really another state eggs have sulfur
yes smells like when the protesters
[ __ ] is in my fitting they've been
protesting all day in the Sun and their
[ __ ] just it's a rough
screaming screaming like this yeah and
their ass is it my nose like it's okay
I'm sorry I accused you of that that's
all right that's all right okay so you
got the work done so I went to health
nucleolus now they do a full body MRI at
the bottom as an hour and a half you
know in a comment amount that's a aren't
happy in a tunnel
you're I'm claustrophobic well so I'm
not so it's not a problem but the
problem is it's an hour and a half where
you just have to sit there and the sound
is this gang gang gang
and yet stay very still listen your pot
a podcast with music not you forgot
didn't you can't and I'll tell you why
they gave me music it's too loud it's
too loud you can't hear anything and you
can't have headphones they have to be
their headphones why cuz it's magnets or
you can't have any metal so there's that
and here's what was disconcerting
they take thirteen thousand images of
your head your whole body and they're
looking for tumors they find any tumors
you didn't do the results but I didn't
get the results back but I don't like
that they're looking that carefully you
wanna get your age like you never one
just pop up well yeah I mean it's true
that if I do that you like it'd be nice
to know that beforehand it'd be nice
like I look you guys I touch that time
the die for the for the USC I forget I
think it's fight in California you stab
real strict real strict like you guys no
sir regulations
I always keep this to myself yeah I
should be the strict sweet to get a cat
scan an MRI everything dystonia and they
do it and he become he's I yeah I need
to talk you man coming he's my friend my
friend work for the Broncos I've great
guy from genius straight-up genius went
to Harvard when he's like 14 yeah dr.
Chad and so I'm like he's a hey can you
stop by the office like you know if 31
just [ __ ] about you know supple as I
don't know
Broncos oh my so we did you're in he was
like flipping through like source
magazines like oh yeah we did it
everything's good get this tumor in the
back but if the yeah man it's not a big
deal I'm like what you say think it's
tumor but I'm pretty sure you're born
with it but we should probably keep an
eye on it cuz sit in the back it's like
oh I thought its back there
but I was just keep an eye on it because
it grows and yeah you're gonna have to
surgeon take your brain like you said
you'll die if you say they can't really
take it out real things like it's in its
ass in a spot where he couldn't operate
because they do irreplaceable damage we
couldn't function so that was fun and
then Brennan I got my car and I could
not stop Christ can i sir I didn't tell
anyway I don't tell anybody he had to
sign like special waivers to California
Commission being like it's a benign
tumor it hasn't grown which he doesn't
know he took my he took the MRI when I
or what that scan when I was what
24:25 no idea what it looks got like
that can tell if it's a glioblastoma
though usually usually oh why cause he
invented the brain surgery what'd you do
with the robotic arms that's his that's
his thing that he came up he went too
hard for his 14 dude yeah so I believe
him oh yeah oh you'd be dead by now sir
we'll see you know oh dude oh my my
friend my friends my friends sister just
had brain surgery and she had she had
one a new seizure and they were like oh
you got a tumor in your brain but it was
a benign tumor and then they had to go
through her eyelid they went through
under her eye and took that [ __ ]
thing out she'll be fine but she said
the pain she goes I'm the pain I am I
literally can't take this headache she
was on morphine the pain for after the
surgery or yes - the nurses been through
all this she goes why is it hurting I've
never felt this kind of pain before in
my head and the nurse goes well have you
ever had brain surgery before Jim point
you know everything's right someone
drill in your skull yeah through the
front the pain was at a nine now it's at
a four so it's getting better but chance
the video the car on fire yes it is hey
B yeah this Saturday USC 215 Achtung
Baby Baby it's pretty stacked card and
guess what you like watching the fights
how about you make a little money with
what half kings you make money with drag
queen yeah the leader in one day fantasy
sports is putting you in the center of
the action when I got about $1,000 from
top prizes 100 while a free shot at
$1,000,000 top prize with your first
deposit well you vent try to get fancy
MMA is easy to play just pick six
fighters stander the salary cap pile up
the points for advances takedowns and
more there's no better way to put your
MMA knowledge to the test than to
compete for one shot at 1 million
million million dollars dollars and from
limited-time draftkings is offering both
new and old users a deposit bonus up to
$500 download the draftkings app now and
use the promo code fighter to get free
at 1 million dollars top prize with your
first deposit that's promo code fighter
to get a free shot at 1 million dollars
with your first deposit only at
draftkings minimum 5 dollars required
deposit bonus requires a 25 x
playthrough eligibility research
apply see graph King stock up for
details hems for hems comm you want hair
you want sexual wellness they got you
this is not this is not gas station
stuff this is science dude I'm not
worried about my haters I'm not worried
about my hair but you have to wait are
you worried about your dong I'm worried
about the Santa kind of waking up they
got your dick bro everybody a lot of
people have erectile dysfunction forty
just said dude struggle unless you're a
complete stallion like myself you're
right you're right when I get my hems
hair stuff I have to tell our business
managers I'm like it's not for my dick
but they got it for your dick if you
need now here's the thing welder that
hims kicks in 40% of men face 40
struggle would not be able to get or
maintain an erection 40% dude but you
don't want to be waiting on doctors
often to tell a doctor you don't have to
you can do it from your phone you can
literally have a text come look another
man the iron my dick thought five
minutes you got your dick pills five
minutes you got your hair hands connect
you with real licensed doctors and FDA
approved pharmaceutical products a treat
edie well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescription to help you
combat IDI stop worrying about multiple
in-office doctor visits alright so easy
it's a few questions but American
history took me from chat with the
doctor and then they review it and guess
what your little pills show up and then
your dicks all happy games free online
visit go to hims calm slash fighter IDI
for now I'm sorry for hems go to forums
calm slash fighter IDI as an erectile
dysfunction that's for hims calm fighter
IDI very quick prescription products are
subject to doctor approval and require
an online consultation again I've done
this with a physician will determine if
a prescription is appropriate in and out
in five minutes I'm a customer it's f o
Rh ima Vlad calm slash fighter IDI
remember that's for hims calm slash
fighter IDI hopefully yours picks up
take my money me go
what's the 101 there
now now is that a certain mode you're in
right now no I mean I'm in manual so
when you rev it up and slow down and
wrap it up again it starts you know sick
well there you go you everything say
about racial disparity how about how do
you how about I don't want to just wait
make one point I've been getting some
text mm-hmm
don't you everything say on social media
Brian you got a lot of fans not the time
right now not the time for me to do that
right now
okay because this is an emotional
catharsis I'm gonna let people have
their say go crazy do that well there's
nothing like unloading I'm downloading
another thing I can say right now
because it's gonna be a nuanced point
that's going to be listened to
I can't go to the looters and go guys
there's a little bit more complicated to
this nobody wants to hear that right now
so how about I bet your boy drew brees
why he's doing interviews right now I
have no idea yeah and they asked him and
I didn't have a problem with that fear
what Theo asked him no no he was doing
like Yahoo Sports yeah who saw works and
they asked him out taking a knee and the
flag and stuff like that and he said he
where he [ __ ] up is where he said I
would never disrespect the flag like
that you know so but he he could
everything he said was perfect except
for that one line which said I would
never disrespect right when I said I'm
like damn you remember in anchorman
where Ron Berger [ __ ] up it was like
[ __ ] you San Diego and the guy was like
why would you do that your poop mouth
you poop mouth you know that yeah that's
how I felt when Drew Brees did that like
[ __ ] dude
you talk about a guy who's been a all
pro pro baller for anything 13 years
he's arguably been the best quarterback
in the in the NFL for the last 10 years
he's MVP Super Ball what he's done for
the city of New Orleans is insane no
player on the planet has done more from
one city than drew Brees if it wasn't
for Drew Brees and when they won the
Super Bowl after Hurricane Katrina all
that [ __ ] remember that and he donated
recently five million dollars out of his
pocket five million dollars he's great
he was back has all these foundations
family man six kids where the [ __ ] he
does you talking about the mr. NFL he's
mr. perfect
he's mr. perfect and then he said
everything is perfect except for the
disrespect part of the flag it's like
God you [ __ ] up Bubba
you [ __ ] up in this
environment is not helpful it's not
helpful but also don't point your anger
toward cuz you can't remember where drew
brees is coming from I'm not defending
because he [ __ ] up my said disrespect
my god dude
but from his persuading your point on
that why do you thought that was a [ __ ]
up
because sailing Newlands disrespected
the flag means you don't understand why
Colin Kaepernick and these other and
greed and stuff and these other players
want to take a knee if they're not
disrespecting the United cerveza we're
to the reason awareness to the to combat
you know the horrible you know condition
that comes the police force and black
people and black lives matter so it's
not a matter of disrespecting military
in the America it's a they're taking a
knee because they don't agree with the
current state he said this his whole
thing I've been hijacked by people who
had other agendas to correct correct but
but you gotta really didn't no one's
done more for a city yeah in any facet
maybe LeBron Ohio but even that's not
right no one's done more per se than
Drew Brees a New Orleans Saints luhan's
for drew drew Brees they'd be the
Santonio sing yeah they were getting a
leave look and by the way also there's
so much more to point your guns that
ordinance black better to point your
negative energy at than drew brees man
he's one of the good guys
y'all see I remember drew brees grew up
in locker rooms
he's from Texas so he grew up in very
diverse locker rooms with black people
out of black Matt a lot of black men and
he's been a leader he's been kind of the
voice the thing that's disappointing is
when you say and this I get like people
are upset
we can't ask for the man be lose his job
or doesn't make him a bad human being
because when he goes it's disrespect
like Miss oh you just you you just don't
understand that fit stoned effort I
don't understand what the message little
tone deaf to now like giving it but I
guarantee you if he watches Malcolm
Jenkins response he'll understand what
the message what are your mouth did you
see that I'd like to see it I send it
Vilia he blasts out because you know
deleted understands sports and he goes
can you know check this out boy and I
said well and I tried to break it down
for him and I said when Malcolm Jenkins
comes out when Malcolm Jenkins comes out
huzzah he's basically the captain in the
defense when you see him talk every
non-black proceeding backwards if you're
on educate on what why it's important
why they feel this way ostracize and you
know why they are so adamant about this
is such a bigger deal than you're making
it watch Malcolm Jenkins responds and
you're gonna go holy [ __ ] I get it if
you don't you're sociopaths ATS what I
mean is I that's why I can make this
show yeah yeah that's why I kept my
mouth shut because you should and you
said because if you're not involved you
know what sometimes it's okay not to
have opinion things if you don't know
what the [ __ ] warrants it's okay to just
let people have their voice first and
then this is gonna come out arguments
gonna come out there about if this is
not lost on people who are people who
are like there are a lot of people who
are into the black lives matter movement
who understand that there are nuances to
this argument right now though it's time
to have an emotional catharsis for
whoever and and and the nation has been
mobilized the world's been mobilized and
it'll change some culture but it's okay
to educate yourself and then have an
impact correct let me hear this and if
you don't know what to say you don't
have to say I'm saying goddamn thing but
educate yourself on why the protests are
going on not diluting the writing if
your focus on that you're [ __ ]
missing the dollar that's right
but watch this and tell me that you're
not more educated after this also real
quick it's Yahoo Finance not Yahoo
Sports not that thank you posit posit
posit so he's one of the best defense
players in the league for a long time
he's basically captain in the defense
over there now and he's a veteran and so
it's gonna be drew brees it's his team
but it's also his team everyone respects
it so you gotta realize where he's
coming at you alright good superstar
[Music]
and we need help and what you're telling
us is don't ask for help that way actual
different way I can't listen to it when
you acts that way we're done asking drew
and people who share your sentiments who
express those and push them throughout
the world the airwaves are the problem
and it's unfortunate because I
considered you a friend I looked up to
you
he's somebody when I had a great deal of
respect for but sometimes you should
shut the [ __ ] up our communities what's
going yeah yeah so this is a 42 oh you
don't have the full clip oh no you need
to fold a little thing this is important
to listen yeah it's important but you
can also see you know when you read it
in a tweet or you read it like that
you're like all right that's fine when
you see the whole thing how it affects
oh yeah dude and the passion you know
what I know you know what I know about
being black in America not like not a
damn thing
exactly nothing news oh yeah so I'm
finalists and look look I'll get to
LeBron James is being made policing is
gotten better policing has gotten better
it's become more diverse it is people
the police have done I've raised
different ways to go those everybody
does everybody does
there you go four minutes importantly
plays the kids are funny cuz they don't
[Music]
do briefs
if you don't understand how hurtful
how insensitive no comments are you are
part of the problem to think that
because your grandfather's served in
this country and you have a great
respect for your flag that everybody
else should have the same ideals and
thoughts that you do is ridiculous and
it shows that you don't know history
because when our grandfathers fought for
this country and served and they came
back then come back to a hero's welcome
they came back and got attacked for
wearing our uniforms they came back to
people to racism to complete violence
and then here we are on 2020 with the
whole country on fire everybody
witnessing a black man dying at the hem
being murdered at the hands of the
police with isn't this in cold blood for
everybody to see the whole country is on
fire
and the first thing that you do is
criticize one's peaceful protest that
was years ago when we were trying to
signal a sign for help and signal for
our allies and our white brothers and
sisters the people we considered to be
friends to get involved it was ignored
and here we are now with the world on
fire and you still continue to first
criticize how we peacefully peacefully
protest because it doesn't fit in what
you do and your beliefs without ever
acknowledging that the fact that the man
was murdered at the hands of police in
front of us all and that it has been
continuing for centuries that same
brothers that you break the huddle down
with before every single game the same
guys that you believe with and gone
about with every single day go home to
communities that have been decimated
drunk unfortunately unfortunately you're
someone who doesn't understand their
privilege you don't understand the
potential there to have to actually be
an advocate for the people that you call
brothers that you don't understand the
history and why people like me people
with my skin color whose grandfathers
fought for this country who served and I
still protested against that against
them not against the national anthem but
against what was happening in America
and what outside the fabric of this
country is for or stands for if you
don't understand that other people
experience something totally different
than you then when you talk about being
the Brotherhood and all this other
[ __ ]
it's just lip service or something on
the field when we step off the sphere
and I take my helmet off on I'm a black
man walking around America and I'm
telling you I'm dealing with these
things I'm telling you my communities
are dealing with these paints and your
response to me is don't talk about that
here this is not the place you where is
the place drew I'm disappointed I'm hurt
because why the world tells you and
you're not worried that your life
doesn't matter the last places will be
here from a lot of guys that you that
you go war with and that you consider to
be allies and to be your friends
even though we're teammates I can't let
this lie Wow powerful [ __ ] Wow the
most what I think he's ever done but uh
like you know I'm saying it's no power
you know my job is there just to listen
and hear that [ __ ] man that that's
that's not some that's not some liberal
anti [ __ ] I that's not that's it that's a
man who deals with things here's the
thing though so when Shannon Sharpe who
I love Shannon Sharpe love Shannon
Sharpe when my favorite people on earth
but when Shan Sharpe goes on the hit
their version of first stake on Fox
Sports and goes drew brees knees retire
right now that Locke comes everybody
same that's the problem no no we know
Kate we know Drew's brings you get
person we know he's done more than the
community than anybody else in the NFL
we're all learning so now I assume drew
breezing like holy [ __ ] you're right my
back now you have an ally now you can
make the correct changes and help it and
be a bigger voice for everything but
when you go nope you're out you're off
the island no no because he tell you no
no change his mind
his mind that that's [ __ ] educational
what he did was I promise you did that
not help you
it helped me it should help I'm gonna
live for a while that I help you cut I
live a long time I can mount a lot of
arguments I combined a lot of arguments
but I was I was talking one of my oldest
friends Mike any fights was black and
grew up in this country I said I was
saying I was trying to pick his brain on
this thing and I had some points and he
said that's all true Brian but not now
yeah not right now that's not this is
not the time to talk this is it time to
listen let this happen now let me dive
into LeBron James so then LeBron James
goes wow man posting the Drew Brees
thing wow man it's still surprising at
this point sure isn't you literally
still don't understand why cap was
kneeling on one knee has absolutely
nothing to do with the disrespect of the
flag and our soldiers men and women who
keep our land free my friend law was one
of those people man who fought as well
this country asked him a question about
it and thanked him all the time for his
commitment he never found cat peaceful
protests protests offensive because he
and I both know what his right is right
and what's wrong is wrong god bless you
here's the problem with LeBron James
well LeBron remember remember when those
those protests in Hong Kong
going on you murdered that in China well
China is a huge market for the MBA and
remember when that I think Fox on Fox
News when LeBron came out and said
something and she goes shut up and play
basketball and when the NBA was
threatened with losing business in China
and Hong Kong because the comments what
did they do they shut up and play
basketball because they didn't want to
deal with the repercussions of financial
losses so with LeBron you were all about
that your shoes are made in China you
don't stick up for that but many wants
to eat so if you're gonna be that way
you have to be that way all the time
otherwise to Malcolm Jenkins point when
he goes that bra bra bra we're out man
if you don't understand we're [ __ ]
out with LeBron what what there's tons
of Chinese people how about the factory
workers the Hong Kong people they can't
say [ __ ] they get arrested they get
murdered
yeah are you kidding me and disappear so
so but but then when it affected your
bottom dollar you weren't about the
cause but now you watch so you I can't
have you picking and choose a good point
it's a it's like do any buttons LeBron
could be right and wrong to you know I
read again please learn again take a
hundred percent I'm not saying you don't
want him out leave my shirt I'm a LeBron
flight besides besides Kevin Durant
LeBron is my favorite player I think the
Lakers are gonna win the chance I
followed basketball
I would agree no they're gonna be good
Demming the Clippers this year they're
gonna because you know basketballs
coming back what's this say let me get
this out block out of the way you know
you can't pick and choose when you're
gonna say oh they're mistreated their
mystery when affects your bottom dollar
we're yeah when it comes your bottom
dollar where you at what does he say
here LeBron James sees the first time to
the NBA's trip to China sees rockets on
a second era
LeBron James speaks for the first time
since NBA's trip to china says Rockies
GM was misinformed about the
ramifications tree and not educated
about the situation so this is when that
the Houston GM was like not [ __ ] in
man yep in the Brunswick whoa he's
misinformed because it affects your
bottom dollar
now you're telling people to be quiet
what's that sound like yeah the same
[ __ ] you're upset about but that's
across the sea so it's not that big of a
deal
that's
isu that's that's that's fair that's a
very very smart begin he's my second I
ride with LeBron
he's my staying very player but he can
be wrong and you can watch every with
him he can be wrong and I hate we as
human beings guys poor listen you're
young and you're trying to formulate
your view of the world you're gonna have
inconsistencies and your thoughts and
your beliefs I I do it all the time one
of the frustrating things about trying
to be on the side of right is that you
are going to be [ __ ] and consistent
and all we can do is just keep did this
is a verb this is a verb let's keep
moving forward and driving you know what
helps being it totus you but you know
what helps and it helped since I met you
is if when you understand history and
this thing's have this has gone before
all around the world we understand
history you understand why this is a big
deal just starts as a small deal to
become a really big that's right so when
you and everyone's mad at me and Brian
for saying [ __ ] we're not wearing masks
oh you guys you want people died I don't
want people to die what I don't want is
my government to force me to wear a mask
just starts there then goes our curfew
and the next thing you know it leads to
some other [ __ ] that was the bigger deal
it's not these small things these my
night these mining things aren't my new
it becomes that and it gets a really big
deal what you think's normal at the time
it's not normal
exactly that's exactly right that's
exactly right so [ __ ] is moving quickly
man and we're all just trying to figure
it out we're all just trying to this is
the dance this is the peculiar dance
Americans have been having this black
and white especially dance this this
weird dance and trying to figure it out
and and and trying to create equality
this is see what makes us realize I grew
up in locker rooms so to me the the the
black pee in my locker rooms I'd have to
do well my friends were black
neighborhood they're black but that's
that's all I knew and then if we're in
the locker room they were treated fairly
if not better because they're so good at
sports so too I didn't grow up around
those weird biases but then you get out
of that holy [ __ ] man it's a different
world art is you into the real world
yeah I'm saying yeah so drew brees is
trying his best now but now were there
was there a protest last night st. [ __ ]
drew brees yeah there is everything for
every person what happened said [ __ ]
drew brees do you realize what he's done
for that community you [ __ ] idiot
yeah you realize what that man's done
[ __ ] me he should have a chance to
apologize
educated himself learn make amends and
and move on oh and also otherwise we're
not otherwise we're not changing
anybody's mind I cancel everyone soon
you keep going you singing it's s'prise
well know that what you do is here now
you really create teams and nobody wants
teams but well here's the other yeah
educate yourself you get the point of
Education but also let me just say this
the point of education is really
important is to understand the
difference between a good idea and a bad
idea and to know when a bad idea
presents itself you have to read broadly
and widely you have to listen most
importantly and and that's a constant
process drew brees is now more educated
he's a better person than he was he's a
more compassionate person he's able to
kind of put this into perspective
education also gives you [ __ ]
perspective so just be a little bit more
what is the word compassionate right
open-minded open-minded allow people to
make their mistakes and try to change
minds and Striders try to destroy you
can destroy somebody against somebody or
you can try to change their mind what
are you doing to persuade and change
people's minds that's the question and
also when you when you start canceling
people especially athletes when people
go god
I don't like athletes or politicians
just give these cookie cutter answers
well why do you think they do it because
if they say one thing out of place they
get [ __ ] drug through the [ __ ] mud
destroyed by people who don't want
change they just want war that that's
the best one show goes on twelve he
should retire right now that lock rooms
everything
Jesus Christ dude what are you talking
about Jan that's not helpful no it's not
helpful
now it's also not true it's not true you
know no it's not true no it's not true
no because I mean he can meet with
Malcolm Jenkins be like dude educate
educate help me so and I talked to the
team I know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about yeah so I don't have a mishap like
or how about this
drew Brees has a perspective as a white
man that's not the same perspective as a
man who's black like he said and and
that's why I kept my mouth shut
I don't know but that's why Macklin
Malcolm Jenkins said you don't know
history you don't man you know what if I
said this to you and I've said this
before maybe on this podcast and for as
much as I've read about American history
I've said this many times I'm always
[ __ ] blown away and I've read a lot
of history and
taking courses on history not just in
college or in history yes I majored in
history but not just in college since
then I go to the teaching come and I
listen to a history of the United States
of me one of the things I'm always
[ __ ] blown away by is the constant
and I'm just and I'm not a liberal
saying this is the constant onslaught
the assault on African Americans from
being starved for resources from being a
redlined they were put why what would
the quake Crescent why is there a black
ghetto in every city is it because black
people want to live that way it's
because they were called it's called red
line they represent only choice they
were put into [ __ ] neighborhoods you
couldn't buy a house you couldn't get a
loan explain for people you wouldn't get
alone when they when they made
properties they redline certain
properties that weren't valued good
income housing yesyes what the
minorities went there yeah and then when
they would go to apply for loans at
banks they turned them down so they're
forced to stay there while white person
you apply for a loan own property yes
investments up through the 90s so listen
up through the 90s this was and so so
what would happen is if you own a house
in a neighborhood and a black family
moved into that house ready for this it
would lower your houses value it would
lower your your income as a white person
okay and banks knew this everybody knew
this and whether you want to say it or
not there go it was there was a cop
there was an expression there goes the
neighborhood
how do you get wealth through property
yes an investment so when a black only
moved in yeah when I don't tell you a
story when a black family moved in it
was there goes the neighborhood
and that's what they would say and your
property value would go down so what did
they do this was a this was this is when
you talk about systemic racism you're
talking about in the system you couldn't
get a loan for a house even if you had
the same credit score even if you had a
better score than anybody who's white
even if you were a doctor allure you
could not get a loan to get a house in a
white neighborhood you had to get on the
other side of the tracks that is who
Watkins called red line that's why there
were black and those those listen this
those neighborhoods were starved of
resources as soon as there were budget
cuts or whatever they're the first one
of the first communities that didn't get
they didn't get that that's just a
historical thing of worse teachers yes
that's a historical fact that's just a
fact and so you have to look at those
things and how black people have lived
for this long it'll make you more
compassionate it'll make you more
understanding make you realize the big
picture that it's a systemic problem
it's a justice process what why there's
so have we made progress [ __ ] yes how do
you change it be doo doo doo Rob
undefeated stores do you rob no you go
you you educate yourself you go to like
you go to the ballot box and you look
then you and me fo you vote you vote
that's the only way you vote vote out
you organize what killer Mike said was
true that's not a threat to white people
it's not kill a Mike is a [ __ ]
educated dude he's not some far left
liberal or anything else and and you
hear more and more of this among black
people including the Floyd's brother
educate yourself we're a peaceful family
don't burn down businesses Chrissy
Teigen and and John Legend they're
they're given money to bail out
protesters all right I understand him I
understand but there you could also give
money to I'd rather see that $200,000 go
to bailing out minority-owned businesses
that might go even a little farther
after after it's been burned down to the
ground let's not criticize anybody right
here criticizing when people say this is
again education when people go all those
places to get looted broke into they'll
just file for insurance
well the way insurance works is in the
it doesn't count for looting the natural
does that it doesn't work another earth
it doesn't work when my daughter gets
her violin so they're ruined my daughter
gets a violent Roma family that there's
there's a music store in Santa Monica
it's owned by a Hispanic family that
Hispanic family those children go to and
and I think yeah where my kids go and
this wasn't known to me until my friend
Jeff Foley told me this but that that
that family is a Hispanic family the two
kids share a bedroom in a one bin in an
apartment they don't have money they
sell musical instruments that store was
looted destroyed they took all the
instruments sure it doesn't pay that
back there for insulin pay of it so we
know that we know that enough to make
you we know that we know yeah
give me some whiskey give me some brown
liquor um is that the 23 year old yeah I
got you both that's nothing like there's
nothing like justice drew brees issued
an apology everything he said 99.8% what
he said was great especially on the mark
but then the money the disrespect thing
but you see more NFL players take in
these we're learning man as a nation
this this country was called the great
experiment and there's a reason for that
it's it's that once this is Drew Brees
talking I'm sorry Instagram I make
comments that were insensitive and
completely missed the mark on the issues
we are facing right now why do the
interviews beyond me drew they lacked
awareness and any type of compassion or
empathy instead these words have become
diverse in her foot and have misled
people into believing that somehow I am
an enemy this cannot be further from the
truth
and it's not accurate reflection my
heart or my character this wife Stan I
think it was in the whole thing very
long it's too long keep going keep going
other thing goes I and I love this
because I have always in all capital
letters always been allied never an
enemy I stick I'm sick about the way my
comments were perceived yesterday but I
take full responsibility recognize that
I should do less talking and more
listening and when the black cami is
talking about their pain we all need to
listen for that I'm very sorry and I
have and I asked for your forgiveness
that's fair man of course this as a
human being if we can hey hey
were you the same person you were when
you were 16 if you're thirty right now
we use the same person you were when you
were 25 and if you're 35 right now if
you are you holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] am i
different yeah and I'm a slow [ __ ]
learner so I have a lot of compassion
for you I'm a slow learner and I'm fine
I've said it before I've been way way
more wrong than I have been right I
[ __ ] up
in many ways as a husband as a father I
was telling Brennan yesterday I [ __ ]
up but I got I'm trying to get better
and we all are and that's all I can do
so just now oh there he goes for him to
admit that it was wrong I think there's
a leadership at its finest Demario Davis
tomorrow Davis it's a good uh it's good
in a safe linebacker yeah I tell you
what went count wouldn't count out the
Saints win the Super Bowl after this
it's gonna make him closer that's the
way fast and football team that's the
way this [ __ ] go do you learn
this the net the net effect of all this
I think is gonna be I really do think
it's a positive ultimately well not
coming late for this I'll see a wave of
energy but rather than me to movement
how worked oh this is terrible and it
went so far where you know the people
got kind of crosshairs have to crack a
few eggs to make an omelet some people
weren't that bad but it [ __ ] went all
the way over here
and now it's back to here and I think we
all ignore the guy who works in
Hollywood without problem yeah and of
course it had a problem we just talked
to a very famous director about that
correct we talked to somebody who
doesn't complain on you and I well the
the the biggest biggest female brand and
I just had a talk I can say her name
with without a Johanna Jenkins power put
me in something guys it's not we talked
to her for an hour I was like this isn't
about me director of Wonder Woman Wonder
Woman to my over the next Aquaman I
don't know why combo I don't know the
point I was make this about yours my
Wonder Woman side piece in part three
take it easy
he flies over much yes we're gonna take
that whiskey looks here care to way
that's the whiskey bleep it out James
you stop talking listen you're right
I'm a drew brees it right now this is
right now I need to do a statement I
need you to read the reason right now
and let's stop drew breezy
then at the end of the day did this is
somebody who never complains wouldn't
ever talk about it but we had a very
candid conversation about the [ __ ] she
dealt with as a woman crazy [ __ ] and
she's not she's a tough tough [ __ ]
cookie the toughest bottom line is
bottom line is as if somebody in
Hollywood who did a TV show the pendulum
has swung back to the middle it's a
[ __ ] better place to work for women
it's a better place to work for all of
us
it's a more professional workplace we
don't have to deal with the kind of
[ __ ] they've had to deal with that's
a good thing man it's a good thing and
so you know this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
clumsy change is clumsy progress is
[ __ ] clumsy one step back two steps
forward three steps back five steps
forward who the [ __ ] knows just be
patient becomes a and I personally again
this started with me saying haven't
posted anything because I'm in the
process of listening I'd rather listen
to dudes like Malcolm Jenkins the most
powerful thing he's done
I think guy damn good
guy that was good powerful should get
him on the podcast powerful damn I'd
love to get how about how about my boys
stacks he's become a voice during this
insane time Steven Jackson became a huge
voice fax made a comment about it was he
went deep to Judy on Drew Brees
so he kind of went hard on him I don't
want to listen to it how long is it it
shouldn't be that long but well we've
already heard I think I'd rather keep it
Alec okay yeah I got to keep it to what
Malcolm Jenkins that that's all I'm
battling I was beating - smart guy
though yeah now I remember he's really
close situation because the man who was
murdered was his 20 good close friend
yeah when he when he have you seen oh
it's emotional when he has his daughter
on the shoulders and his daughter's
going look my dad changed the world yeah
I can't see that I can't see that right
now yeah how about they did convict the
other three officers yeah I was
surprised because here's the great thing
about are two of them didn't look that
white yeah once one Bayesian the other
one looks like he's half a South
American yeah the great thing about
America but nobody again educate
yourself how the how the the system
works is people like why was it it soon
or why is it sooner you have to have all
your ducks in the row and the
prosecution talked about this when
you're trying to convict police officers
they get off ninety nine percent of time
because if you don't have your ducks in
the row when the jury comes in they
assume the police are doing the best
they can with what they have
so to prosecute police officers so
[ __ ] tough you have to have evidence
you have all your ducks in a row before
you try to convict these men of murder
now they're gonna be abating and aiding
right yeah I don't know it's gonna be
interesting to say well you gotta listen
to guy listen to the voice of it cuz one
of them definitely at the white guy
looks racist but I pray go the Asian the
Asian guy one of them does go man I feel
like you should turn him over he
shouldn't be on his back that long and
then the the guy who's gonna be
convicted of murder without a doubt he's
like no he's fine but that there I think
was they using twice goes you should
probably roll him over man she probably
roll him over so he probably gonna be
okay but the other guys are [ __ ]
rightfully so
well what was this guy doing on the far
end there before I left
yeah do we know I don't you know what
not
yeah you know what not enough not enough
not enough oh you know what no not
enough well I like how the dude who's
charged for murder his wife filed for
divorce she's agent 2 by the way guys
and also this is going to make this is
this is going to make a difference
what's gonna happen with police officers
is they're all gonna be [ __ ] careful
every police officer who and most of
them do a [ __ ] great job and keep us
safe god [ __ ] bless them but every
police officer it's gonna go I don't
want to be I don't want my I promise
they're gonna go I don't want to be one
of those three guys in a mug shot I
don't give a [ __ ] of my vision I don't
I'm gonna be super careful and then our
mayor of law says goes you know what
let's take funding from the police
department yeah well gar said yeah oh
yeah that my age of life's rio de la bro
like I said though that that maybe when
you say defunding the police you might
be taking for every large pension plan
there's a way to dock those numbers so
it looks good politically but it's not
gonna fall speaking from personal
experience my family member who's a cop
well they're a deduct 10% of his salary
there's gonna be things like that that
are done kind of which which look you
got to deal with the police union there
are a lot of things that are gonna be
done like that are that look good and
and and right now everybody's got a take
on take you got to take a seat for a
second it's tough it's tough you know
we're all we're all this is it hey hey
how about 2020 Spring 2020 has Pinnell
[ __ ] oh hi oh my god - there was an
earthquake by me like [ __ ] off [ __ ]
battle snakes everywhere we should have
known we should you know what we did
that rattlesnake you make snakes no what
now yeah didn't almost bite me but I
like yeah I scared you did but got
scared did well let me see this
they're back everything you in a while
I'm scared I'm so scared
is that a robber oh yeah you didn't hear
it rattling you're gonna fun it's not
fun
that's not now that now go back now
that's not easy up hill sir no it's not
no I need lunch I advise bike for that
are you using an electric bike on that
yeah I'm using the it's definitely so
hard it's very because that's not like
your normal electric bike that's got to
do a lot of work now I would be the best
bike ride is all right it's the best
bike you might have to get into the
thick boys but yeah I didn't like when
we rap we were at we were at parkour
Brent and I do parkour and I was
standing there when I ger does it no I
went to get my I guess it went to get a
consultation on my lids because I had to
have a consultation on my lids sure now
a couple things you guys need to know
that you don't know I'm getting my lids
done well he said I would do the lower
hell yeah I would do the lower it'll
make a difference nobody's gonna be able
to tell you don't talk about on your
podcast promise you yeah you're gonna
look like the chuck-e-cheese like I'm
always listening
now hold on Brendon I asked him that he
said you're not gonna notice realize
what else they look great because we're
gonna look like this no I'm not your
brow lifts I'm not doing brows I'm just
doing this is you and drew brees agent
calm tone that his [ __ ] dingo over will
you take this yep no listen it's gonna
be fine and you look like that you're
very good hey the best yeah I would say
the peasant gift I'm not gonna look like
that come out like guys watch yourself
you are you notice watch this I go I
know but I my mother told me if you do
that it gets hollow cuz the fat comes
out and he goes oh no no we're gonna
shoot some fat in from you her from your
tummy why does that I don't get it done
I go liposuction I don't want to do that
is it permanent knee goes yeah can you
guys hey oh my god I got a great story
for you guys it's fine they can take fat
out I don't know if I can tell the story
no [ __ ] your story
they can suck fat out and it stays gone
forever they can do anything how about
this maybe I need to see your doctor how
about this my man was I hope I can tell
a story a plastic surgeon a plastic
surgeon
was doing a facelift on a man now fat
plastic surgeons on men take a long time
for whatever reason much longer than
women and their the office was on the
second floor in Beverly Hills okay now
that's Beverly Hills brother mm-hmm the
looters came through oh no it was a
14-hour operation was this the movie
face off what do you think this ready
for this I don't know that's how long it
takes ugly dude a lot of work either way
yeah he's gonna look fantastic
apparently doubt it the looters came
through the pharmacies downstairs they
heard the wood the windows of the
pharmacy break oh they took all that
they heard all the looters they took all
the but they were setting fires Bubba oh
my so you know wake home he's in the
middle of [ __ ] you can't wake him up
his face is his face is half off it's a
movie face off you can't wait Nicolas
Cage did they're there they're operating
on him and they can hear what they can
get up oh you're going back bang bang
and they're on the phones please come on
look they're setting fires to the
building right there if they set a fire
here we're dead and also this guy's dead
he's dead you can't do this
sure and they were and they broke over
us and it was so [ __ ] terrifying and
they're like they were praying and they
the blue ters thank god I guess raided
the pharmacy and then moved on
mm-hm and he finished it up and it was
like what the [ __ ] does the guy wake up
and like we have good news and bad news
good news is what your face is done your
face is you me a lot of pains we have no
painkillers welfare people the looters
took all of them and that's probably we
do have some Tylenol friend that's
probably what happened any good luck
but yeah I'm getting my list on the 16th
I'm gonna need the data but no puppet
you're coming in here I will I'm gonna
be very populist you know I'm gonna come
home I can't wait I'm gonna come in a
big countdown I'm gonna be super puffy
and then for ten days I can't do any
exercise because I can't raise my blood
pressure so no surf and turf and I got
to do the podcast and y'all calm and
then 10 days so 16th on the 25th I'm on
stage in San Antonio is it the 25th I
think so is that when I'm in smoking I'd
love to come San Antonio do that's my
sit right now and I'm it I want to go to
some it the mayor called me is a kid
that cool front comes through I'm like
yeah cool I don't know I know it's my
city I didn't know
my city really mmm congratulations thank
you right relations ah god damn smoke in
the 25th Tony so yeah so I can I'm
staying it just you know you're staying
at my hotel hotel Emma me and Moloch B
and Stevie blue eyes will be there hon
it's gonna be some fun how great is
Moloch basil it's great yeah mark be
calm
he'll be with us in Phoenix he'll be
with us Janelle's Papa Papa you should
see the Airbnb J shop got it's gonna be
it's gonna be me you Moloch and
Chappelle and our nuts gonna be in that
pool and also our boy job a bunch of
nuts young flora and I'm gonna be I'm
not gonna can I wear a speedo around her
no you do I swear my undies hey what the
[ __ ] Moloch why is he showing his body
like that that annoys the [ __ ] out of me
smooth body got a nice respect him
better Moloch I was sweating let her
here's a boxing look that's a good body
right there Bo that's good
midsection all well smooth he's got a
thin midsection little smooth hey hey
handsome dude though I know but why he
sent me a picture of him hey bro okay
better what the [ __ ] hold on this guy
sent me Moloch sent me this this picture
hold on he sent me he goes he sent me a
picture of his back there you guys are
of his back there's a very handsome
gentleman yeah he goes felt like he was
having a bad morning so here's a picture
of my back in a garden for motivation
purposes Jeff Garlin loves Moloch too
cuz Jeff Jeff transmog I mean Moloch
transferring and and opens forum
sometimes you don't seem too thrilled
there ya maliks great when my favorite
people on earth right now crush on him
me and Moloch ever crush now here's the
thing Papa yeah if we're looking at legs
you probably biggest calves I'm second
maltose last he's dead last
Moloch has Moloch has very thin leg him
in John Jones his John Jones let's got
John Jones likes Moloch you know this I
know you're listening you have John
Jones like he's got yeah great joke
about it doesn't owe me ball oh the best
it's funny
oh the best joke have you heard talk
about it yes [ __ ] now Moloch you have
John Jones likes yeah that's right he
does and I know you don't watch anyway
but look up John Jones likes yeah
as you listen this look up John Jones
right that's right yeah I got it I got
to give him some [ __ ] from posing with a
shirt off can't have that I would do the
same thing he's a young dude man Oh what
the [ __ ] is with that that's a good body
right there that's the better body that
pictures he isn't he never lifted
weights cuz he was boxing and now he
started lifting weights and he puts on
muscle quick unlike anything gentlemen
yeah yeah we're Moloch fans all right
now um dude you should suck him off in
Arizona I don't like that in the pool no
I'm straight hey what the [ __ ] was that
go back look at the quote love is the
only force that will put ego to rest so
much love to you all brah Marla hey how
dare you he's like threw a tree my
favorite thing is one of his homeboys
like yeah all right let me let me try to
get the right picture I hope you answers
you know him in Chappelle our boys oh
yeah it's great
[Music]
hey your service [ __ ]
hey Moloch he can't see this is a
nightmare
there you go we'll get back down papa so
June 16th what day is that chin look at
the 16th I just called you researchers
no Bryan will be back good yeah oh hey
Malik
we're on the podcast right look at the
quality you're like looking all
seductive the behind foliage it's
plainly [ __ ] - man which one of your
boys took the picture
the plan we got a share of room we got
to share a house in Arizona so I need
some answers flyer like the back of an
R&B album oh yeah that picture got the
most likes and women love seductive
looks for worse that will put you know
you go to rest so much love to you all
bruh what but why brah that'd be awesome
so much love ladies like Street Street
or gay why the [ __ ] did you send me a
picture of your back for quote-unquote
motivational purposes this morning that
was [ __ ] up your back is not about for
not about peace I like it we don't need
no you're not making a difference with a
goddamn picture of your back how would
you describe your back said that [ __ ]
you said your back isn't authority
figure [ __ ] Amy that's so arrogant
molecule I thought shoes for an hour
I appreciate everybody shout out the
British keep the fire on the feed dogs
congratulations Maulik you need to post
that you need a post and say I'm coming
Phoenix that should that should be your
your headshot yeah that's what I do
no don't do that
that makes me super angry don't do that
okay close the picture back and say the
road to Phoenix starts here no nobody
said that either man this is all right
this whole thing is turning out to be a
disaster we I gotta get back to podcast
we love you later handsome bastards
handsome right cat he's good-looking
he's very handsome when I post that
video I had a bunch of girls be like
who's that he cute yeah good dude
not only has five hundred likes that's
okay I'll get there hilarious there you
go to be fair he has a lot of horror
emojis under his photos though a lot of
[ __ ] oh the girls like a lot of girls
do you eat the girls like a lot of
thirsty hoes day how he goes yeah
Phoenix any fun I can't wait for Phoenix
oh it's gonna be phat Airbnb how are you
Jay Sean hopefully Jay Chou gets his
Hoggy out in the pool well listen he
won't he's very I try to poke at his
Hoggy and he won't know it's thick like
an elephant trunk it's got and it's it's
a she's black very dark darkness this
skin is the caucus it's dark I'm serious
he never gets it out all the time 2001 I
saw a black guy there's a picture of a
black guy at a protest holding
holding up a sign that says you're your
daughter's love every inch of us why
can't you like that's the greatest
[ __ ] thing I've ever seen my that's
fantast
that's [ __ ] up I was like god damn it
mm-hmm
should we do some current events sure
man I feel like we touched on the
current event yeah kind of oh yeah I saw
this oh this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah oh okay
this was sent in from many underscore
1987 on Instagram this has been
circulating where a woman asked this
construction worker if she could take a
photo with his screwdriver
yeah his power drill and she wanted the
photo to look like she was helping these
companies board up this happened
actually on Third Street Promenade here
in Santa Monica
somebody had this video of her and they
posted it online originally no one could
really tell who it was because she had a
face covering but when it got on to
Twitter people realized that woman looks
familiar they found out she was a
journalist she was an intern at The
Washington Post I believes for an
ostrich ah yes yes watch the video real
quick very pretty
we get her boyfriend if I could see
where she hurt - wait what'd she look
like she was yeah but she looks like she
was gone defender B nope she did nothing
no no she looks like she's pretending to
board up a store yes yes like she's
absolutely like doing work out here on
Third Street guys matter you don't say
yeah yeah it's pretty terrible yeah her
man
I like that social media exposes phonies
mm-hmm
God dang yeah that was very weird and
they got their lot her license plate as
well I wonder how many people actually
do that I'm sure a lot of people
actually do that - oh sure and then
paint retweeted what is wrong with these
entitle [ __ ] who the [ __ ] are you
and who are your parents you horrible
person how can you defend this so so um
can I ask this 24 million views what
what did what did she say when she
posted it I didn't see her Instagram
account actually went private very
quickly after this video went up so a
lot of people don't know if she ended up
posting it or not and people don't know
what she said if she did post it so
maybe she didn't post it and she was
just home I found out before yeah I
don't know is this is this what was she
doing was she just doing it to be silly
I don't think so she doesn't look like a
daddy where's another that's not I'm
asking you I don't understand what what
a stupid question though but this is
someone trying to gain the Graham do it
for the grand Homme I look like you yeah
we know if she posted or not we don't
she went private very good it because
the video went out I know but we're
assuming we she did to post it well why
else would you do it though I'm just a
maybe like hey look I'm boarding
something up to her friend or something
I don't know like I'm you sweet no but I
I mean you'll it's done you're sweet no
I I'm a little confused about it that's
all it's pretty easy to figure out be at
least social media account after mm-hmm
yeah
yeah I'm hilarious
anyway um what's next I don't know what
the [ __ ] she's thinking as if 2020
couldn't get any weirder [ __ ] Ebola is
back and it's in the Congo it has now
Ebola likes the heat I think it likes
the he fits in the Congo it likes the
yeah yeah so five people in the Congo
were a girl [ __ ] yeah yeah there was an
outbreak five people ended up dying and
four other people who came into contact
with that fifteen year old girl is
currently in critical condition
passed by body fluids and has a tilt the
fatality rate of anywhere between 25 to
90% yeah this this by the way you want
you want a quarantine hard
let's lock down the economy for Ebola
fit right right away don't happen if you
lied where's the outbreak though waiting
but listen because code legit that those
are clapping all confirmed of them have
it oh no I do pathway but Brennan Palais
but we're outbreak but the protest this
is were social distancing and wearing
masks and that's the only reason it
hasn't broken out but we were warned
that there could be another spike I'm
waiting there is one they just keep us
in there yo well all the testing is
closed right now due the Oh bra oh but
there's three seven days they get that
far the hospitals are around they'll say
the hospitals over rhymes configure the
hospitals will shut down the economy
should we keep shutting it down but it's
so weird because I don't think anybody
wants Sophia sitting there but you were
at San Diego at the beach everybody be
having a great time at two weeks ago you
can arrest people at the beach for being
too close but then the protesters
they're fun oh that's weird
yeah oh yeah anyway you know something
about the protests here since I mean I
live in the like the heart of downtown
LA the first one that happened was crazy
alright it was violent a lot of stuff
and then days after it was super
peaceful
yes and more people - yes it's beautiful
yeah the protest is in general are a
great thing yeah it's gotten so much
better
idiots and this is just a silly video
from barstool this guy is gonna attempt
to jump onto a trampoline through the
ring - so tight mcbaggy to me
well he's the most through it he went
right through right so I just laid on
top right on top of the fire did you see
when Tom Brady was golfing he bent down
to pick up the bomb ripped his [ __ ]
pants now on live national TV goes pick
up his ball and his [ __ ] khakis just
out the back that's a problem I think I
saw him you know it's hard to deflate a
golf that's great
hilarious hey Cohen system [ __ ] wide
open
oh they're big boys cough game is not
good right not good okay you all you
didn't watch it I don't have to wonder
no not gonna get shy huh
yeah but it's very relatable yeah he
doesn't play that much now Peyton
Manning was the monster he's a great
copper yeah yeah made the best shots
more than Tiger Phil Mickelson he tore
it up
Tom was awful he had one great shot
though and here's another silly video
that people keep tagging me in this is a
guy who chose to crossdress he's also
wearing a wig he paid this young lady 20
dollars to kiss her feet seems out there
though oles not seemly she's in good
shape
yes the body is uh she's Asian from
oddworld Adjei he does yeah this isn't
weird all right $20 that's it that's
what I said too much but at the same
time that's a easy $20 a girl I need any
money $20 cat you could make a fortune
huh I cried again it's got a gut it's
like I said I think about he's built
like a from odd world yeah I think
that's the least of his problems yeah
probably
what's next he's cross-dressing in he's
Kissin thief was Nick he's paying Nick
his feet was drew this is audience my
sister chin so look it says pregnant
elephant bites cracker stuff fruit dice
standing in river so when I read that
I'm like they stuffed crackers in a
pineapple and I'm thinking saltines
there's real dry maybe choked on it but
they're they mean firecrackers so what
these people do so the elephants don't
like stomp on their land or wild boar
because the wild boar will [ __ ] up all
their you know crops and stuff they put
pineapple stuff with firecrackers when
they buy them it [ __ ] them up so this
elephant got a hold of it and broke his
like broke his upper jaw a lower jaw
blew off his tongue it was a female just
perfect yeah so sad so that because she
just stayed in the water with her mouth
covered so sad and she died yes I think
people are pissed man
but I was thinking like see her jaw was
broken she was unable to eat up she
shoot the pineapple and exploded in
their mouth outrage tells local media
he's certain that tampered with
pineapples meant to kill the animal
oh wow someone put that there yeah so
people are very angrily in the uck good
luck catching that guy you're just with
the headline and said crackers I'm like
it's that easy to kill an elephant just
toss some crackers in its mouth
I'm saying this yeah so we were talking
about this after well then she lies chin
chin goes well the truce Eagles exploded
given I heard that you could throw an
alka-seltzer meal gonna explode I
presume your friendly idea that seagulls
will explode if it's fed alka-seltzer
all right Carmen a few those wiser
misson refuses to I used to think that
was the case I thought elephant going to
catch yeah God crack we're all learning
takes the files it's easy that's how
easy killer okay that's what they say
like in Iraq and the UK called sneakers
trainers so every article I was like in
Miami so I'm not racist white crackers
races white people you know I own
crackers yes why crack a whip yep
alright so this I guess he's a founder
of off-white a creator of off-white he
did a donation and he put it on his
Instagram or snapchat
he's Instagram so it says here the Miami
community I'm inspired for kids in the
streets that need a bail funds for
George Floyd protests and his show that
he donated $50 so of course people are
going why would you donate so little if
he's pissed because I don't know about
Miami but in LA he came out like Shawn
Witherspoon is a big street guy he did a
collab with Nike some of the best claps
big street artists but like a lot of
these stores you know pink dolphin
undefeat a lot in the flight club a lot
of these stores are black owned and they
braided them and broke all the stores
and you know a lot of it where black kid
then like kids a lot of back in here
just like what the [ __ ] are you doing
man these people give back to the
communities people do so much stuff and
you're raising these things so I think
he was upset by that make sense and
that's what's his way be like [ __ ] you
he also gave 50 bucks what you give so
yeah still 15 now the other the most
important thing I can't believe haven't
talked about that he's the biggest off
White's like all this stuff is so
important but we're still are not
talking about how the Glee cast is
accusing Lea Michele of being saw that
too and I guess she was a real [ __ ]
though you see what she did no what is
she dad heard I heard I've heard that
she's difficult there's a black on set
and I guess she wouldn't let her eat
with the other classmates and then she
said if she went around goes I wish I
could [ __ ] on her wig yeah I don't I
don't believe it's because she was black
but I do believe that she no I'm just
saying I see I don't see his flashes
I've heard she's men and I've heard that
from everybody that she's a real [ __ ] a
source yeah talent that's what a lot of
people have said ever since Glee that's
not good for her it's
it'll be hard she's a lost sponsors like
she had hellofresh
her out so she post something like she
goes Jordan everybody you made my first
living my first television take a living
hell because I'll never forget I believe
you told everyone that if you had the
opportunity was [ __ ] in my wake amongst
other traumatic microaggressions that
made me question a career in Hollywood
whoof STEMI where ya perch is just a
raging [ __ ] remember her boyfriend -
he didn't come he didn't commit suicide
but I overdosed he was a drug at I guess
he was a drug addict as well I need it
passed away while he was with her so
like well I was dating her who knows
what the [ __ ] okay who knows this is
this is a time let's not beat up on
anybody right now yeah [ __ ]
like we're going bad on ly I don't even
know her she's talented as [ __ ] but yeah
I mean she might be a nightmare so what
it's all good and then this I know I'm
not liking Sammy we're who's going bad
on her for posting about George Floyd at
least and she goes oh by the way let me
make it about me that's that's another
actress [ __ ] yeah that was a [ __ ] yeah
hey I don't care about your
microaggressions either so you get over
to because there are bigger things for
then than Glee yeah I think there are
better things you both some cables well
you both suck Lea Michele probably
really sucks maybe your baby don't know
the woman don't know the woman had no
idea sorry I brought it up okay have you
guys raised important thing this story
oh yeah a famous youtuber who does a lot
of videos about you know taking care of
kids and I she did a bunch of videos
with this particular kid from China he
had autism or he has autism and then she
made like a bunch of content with them
which is monetized as well so she
adopted him she she took care of my she
documented the entire journey in the
process stayed with him for a while some
guy who gave him to another he's wrong
we don't know why we laughing know that
so she's a family vlogger her whole
thing is that her and her husband and
her family have a YouTube channel and
she has made it a point to record her
process of trying to adopt a child from
China he just so happens to have autism
and after I guess having him a part of
her family with her other kids she then
realized that
she was not equipped well enough to take
care of a child with autism and so she
found another family to have him adopted
he said that the they weren't open to a
special needs adoption and the kid has a
brain tumor and brain damage okay so I
don't know what it's like
does anybody know is like take care of
that kid because it might be
all-encompassing and she can't do it so
she found a family
people are just upset because she's
obviously making you know quite a bit of
money from documents and all this she
had millions okay accumulated I think it
was millions of views
she's like a hundred hundred thousand
subscribers right now you're a real
[ __ ] right no I I wanted we got enough
of this [ __ ]
so anyways it looks like they're gonna
investigate trial by social media over
here not [ __ ] off not doing any more
this must end this mine this is my voice
how about that you do know you do today
you defend the lady gave up her Dossett
Chinese seven minutes three rocks what's
that and they defend the lady who's a
well-known cut on the set of Glee well I
know we don't know please the greatest
show ever
oh look at this a couple of things so
Kanye West is donating two million to
set a college fund for George Floyd's
daughter and also a lot of money for
colloid Mayweather
um I'll shoot for the page ignore the
funeral now you know costs that's cool
all right I mean one more this is pretty
dope this on worldstar check this out
she's that I
[Music]
is it amazing Nick so that's the lid
amide that's typically thalidomide
so when your mother took up there was
Nancy medication I don't think that he's
too young too happy a little my baby and
he was born deformed that way oh I
thought it was photoshopped what no
that's it yeah that's a deformity whoa
he's able to play panels let me see the
yin to him that's crazy
by the way just really quickly if you
had a job letting the kids like I want
to play piano you'd be like I know
there's of them there are other things
and he's to any place piano like that
hold up
that's amazing I think he made it on The
Ellen Show to school I mean that's
incredible yep drippy underscore 2 X 2
is 4 to 9 Darius Simmons what's the cool
man that's some [ __ ] right there good
thing his family wasn't that YouTube
leaders they'd send them back that's a
difficult one young and he was Asian -
that's not an Asian guy ok that's
alright guy you are chin doesn't see
color Jen doesn't see color unless she's
Asian
yes he color I only see you Navy said it
that's pretty much I mean you guys saw
the Trump the Bible photo op ETS see
that one I don't know how big a deal
that was with the other kind of cleared
out protesters so you could take that
you think the tournament zoo they
actually they didn't tear gas apparently
that's [ __ ] yeah can't believe you
any of the major now you can't nothing
I'll just say [ __ ] and you're like and
then they had out the Dems had a whole
thing going around on social media that
Hitler did the same thing they found I
was a fake picture Hitler all in the
Bible did you hear it did you hear
Justin Trudeau's response and then do
you was it virtuous just watch the first
21 seconds they asked Justin Trudeau
about Trump
just say Justin Trudeau silence yeah
right no one second watch it why
Sebastian dodge this question here's
know what to say Isis this is real
leader you've been reluctant to comment
on the words and actions of the US
president but we do have Donald Trump
now calling for military action against
protesters we saw protesters teargas
yesterday not true to make way for a
presidential photo-op I'd like to ask
you what you think about that and if you
don't want to comment what message do
you think you're sending
[Laughter]
what's he not ready for this question
Wow is this live TV watch in horror and
consternation what's going on in the
United States that's a question it
doesn't matter to him
it just says racism is bad or was that
hey good leadership there Justin yeah
his dad was the three-time Prime
Minister of Canada so he's how are you
not ready for that question
are you not ready for that he was like
he's a very very left-leaning come out
all right guys dude I don't know what
we're gonna do our governor in Marin
California dude they're pushing me out
of la mente yeah
tough job seemed yesterday taking the
knee oh he's a man he's a politician
buddy playing all different sides it's
gotta be a politician the protests on
his house though so that's well don't
expect much from a politician in general
yeah you're right
uh wait until they [ __ ] make us stay
inside right yeah man you know they
never do it yeah it's we better be
careful in New York in LA giving you
let's not use the National Guard why
would we do that in lieu you're [ __ ]
morons
yeah stop this right now you see how
does a show Saturday it's four o'clock
show yeah 7:30 in the 9:30 sold out we
had a four o'clock show me Brian
Chapelle and Moloch will be in Phoenix
next week Thursday Friday Saturday take
that tak calm yeah I'm all sold out so
for that early Saturday that we just
added it could you take a San Antonio
June 25th 26th 27th Bryan Callen you
said you're gonna spoke you right now
whatever spoken we added a Thursday show
there's a Late Show Thursday all other
tickets are sold out that's June 25th
only tickets available 27th during the
first thick boys bike club meeting we
have special merch just for the Spokane
thick boy by club
sign up at a thick boy ride at gmail.com
then Salt Lake City July 16th through
the 18th wise guy Salt Lake City we'll
also be doing a thick boy by club right
there sign up at thick boy ride at
gmail.com for that that's it man
all right big boy merch Bryan's Texan
thick boy merch get it while it's hot we
got new [ __ ] drop them in the summer I
think that's it dude I said buddy get
your lids done I'm getting my list I'm
all right I'll let you know what's going
on with my health this the fun kid bro